[Musique]
dormi à la boulangerie kassav attend
paul suivez-moi
[Musique]
donc je m'appelle valérie lucas j'ai 32
ans je suis là chef gérante de kassav à
l'entreprise qu'on a créé avec mon mari
et on l'a ouvert la boulange 2 en
février 2021
donc mon mari et moi on est diplômé de
l'institut paul bocuse à lyon après ça
on a eu différentes expériences en
france en amérique latine aussi en
australie en restauration
gastronomique mais aussi dans des cafés
dans les bistrots et mon mari aussi en
parallèle s'est formé en boulangerie
principalement dans le pain au levain
c'est après sa dernière expérience en
australie qu on a décidé de rentrer à la
réunion est de faire
vraiment notre projet à nous une
boulangerie ou ont pris également la
cuisine on a été accompagnée par la
chambre des métiers et de l'artisanat à
saint paul qui nous a aidé à peaufiner
notre business plan notamment la partie
financière pour les présenter à
différentes banques
donc qu'à ça va c'est une boulangerie au
levain naturel et artisanale c'est un
pain du cou qui est beaucoup plus sain
qui se conserve très bien et qui a
beaucoup plus de saveur on fait
également de la cuisine donc toute
l'offre snacking et pâtisseries tout est
fait maison avec des produits locaux à
90% on travaille en direct avec des
petits producteurs qui nous livre tous
les jours ces frais tous les jours et on
change du coup le menu tous les jours
donc vous trouverez par exemple qu'on
s'a de poids centre et marinée mais
aussi un sandwich avec la baguette au
curcuma et une réelle de porc que
l'éleveur fait lui même mais qu'on va
récupérer chez lui c'est vraiment une
cuisine look avant
le côté produits pays bas en étant
réunionnaise nous allons rendre revenant
à la réunion j'avais vraiment envie de
mettre en valeur des produits du terroir
réunionnais on travaille que des farines
biologiques des graines biologique est
on
on a encore peur aussi des produits péi
à l'intérieur comme le curcuma comme la
patate douce ce qui nous différencie des
autres boulangeries c'est qu'on est dans
cet esprit ultra locale toute la
pâtisserie aussi que ce soit les
tartelettes les sables et les biscuits
on va essayer de revisiter des
pâtisseries longtemps comme d'état
beyrouth défendant magnol dépendant
patates douces les tartelettes on vous
trouverai pas tartelette aux pommes chez
nous ça va être que des fruits pays que
des fruits de saison donc en ce moment
ça va être la banane la papaye bientôt
c'est le fruit de la passion on est en
phase de l'envié en phase avec les
saisons ont fait des quantités limitées
chaque jour pour qu'il y ait un vrai
roulement des produits et pour limiter
aussi le gaspillage et tout ça c'est
vraiment dans les vies de soutenir aussi
une économie circulaire une économie
locale et vertueuse ça a été un vrai
challenge et surtout en période
d'épidémie donc pour moi le dicton qui
résume vraiment cette aventure c'est
fargo la flamme
[Musique]